pouvez vous décrire je vous prie les
sentiments et sensations que vous
éprouvez quand vous battez votre fils
[Musique]
oui ma chérie d'accord je tire je vois
tout de suite je suis désolé nous allons
devoir abrégé quand vous avez un bébé
c'est toute votre vie qui change vous
deveniez totalement dingue
si tu veux que je m'installe chez vous
non merci maman on s'en sortir on veut
tu prendre soin d'elle si tu ne prends
pas d'abord soin de toi monsieur kool
savas
je suis assistant social tous les jeunes
que je suis sur des enfants à risque
il est encore fait du mal tu sais que je
vais devoir le signaler à la police
il aura ce qu'ils méritent non aller
pour ça je vous dépose quelques pas ce
sera gratuit
s'il vous plaît je vous en supplie s'il
vous plaît avez vous remarqué s'il
arrive à votre mari de s'absenter la
nuit
[Musique]
non insinuer vous que je pourrais avoir
je ne sais quel lien avec cette affaire
qu'est ce que vous ferez quand ils
découvriront votre vraie nature
nous ferions n'importe quoi pour le bien
nourrie
les pères eux font les frayeurs